I'm an Ford I'm an interpreter here
working at the European Council our
purpose is to try to ensure that the
heads of state and government understand
each other as well in 23 languages as
they would normally speaking to each
other in their own language even before
we come into the booth we have a system
whereby we obtain information and
background information for every meeting
online and it's very important that we
are put in the same position as
delegates so we have the same
information but here this is the file we
get for the European Council and when we
come into the booth we come in early so
that we can prepare it we can read
through the letter from the president
the agenda here and then we have all the
detailed documents as we work our way
through the file so this gives us the
vocabulary it gives us the background
but of course this is not the most
important thing it's not about thinking
ahead the most important thing about
interpreting is not the words it's not
the language itself it's the the message
it's the spirit of what's being put
across so it's not a matter of a machine
it's not a matter of a translation that
she's written and takes a long time we
have to be able to listen understand
process and produce it in our own
language and then convey that message
but we have to do it in a very very
short period of time in just some kind
of nanosecond we have to do all those
processes in our head right amusingly
somebody came into the booth the other
day and said I really admire what you do
but of course you have the script
running along a screen in front of you
as they really believed that we had the
script no it's totally improvised
everything that said in this room we can
interpret live and it's actually much
more exciting than when people read
speeches
you